ein wahltag der superlative nie gab es
vorher so viel unentschlossene in
deutschland nie stand es vorher so knapp
spitz auf knopf die letzte umfrage 26 25
zwischen stolz und laschet wirklich nur
soviel und an diesem wahltag der rekorde
der superlative gibt es auch noch die
größte wahlpanne aller zeiten wohl
patrick so unglaublich heute morgen hat
armin laschet seine stimme abgegeben in
der grundschule seiner kinder in seiner
heimatstadt aachen und ihm ist eine
riesige panne passiert hier sehen wir
die bilder gemeinsam mit seiner frau
susanne r steckt seinen wahlzettel
herein dass der entscheidende moment
schauen wir einmal genauer an hier hier
sind die kreuze von armin laschet dem
kanzlerkandidaten bei der cdu gesetzt
das ist richtig falsch daran ist dass
wir alle es sehen können dass das ist
ganz klar ein verstoß gegen das
wahlrecht für alle in der schule gelernt
bundestagswahl muss allgemein frei
unmittelbar gleich und vor allem geheim
ablaufen das ist keine überraschung
genauso wenig geben wie das armin
laschet tatsächlich seine beiden kreuze
bei der cdu macht aber marcel reif wenn
wir das sehen heute da geht man so
zumindest nach außen einigermaßen
entspannt am wichtigsten tag im leben an
die wahlurne ins wahllokal in der heimat
nach die leute grüßen freundlich klopfen
noch mal auf die schulter man denkt die
himmelblaue das wetter usw das läuft
jetzt irgendwie alles und dann das was
wäre das in der fußballsprache
das ist ein zumindest ist das geht in
richtung eigentor ein bisschen ja
ich nehme an armin laschet etikett das
wahlgesetz wobei also mir sagt das
gefühl es ist soll ja denjenigen
schützen der der welt also der darf
geheim geben wenn einer das nicht geheim
bild oder wollte er das so wollte er
zeigen dass er darauf deutschen ist
darauf deutet nichts dahin aber wir
dürfen das rechtlich noch mal auch
politisch ganz in ruhe auf nur ich habe
heute früh auch gewählten in meine moral
büro es war durchaus kompliziert in
berlin weil es so viele verschiedene
stimme ist ähnlich und deswegen stand er
war ja auch überall drauf wie man ihn
falten muss und so war halt verkehrt ja
das ist jetzt ganz wichtig kein
wahlzettel gar nicht nur ein wahlzettel
aber der muss halt nach innen gefaltet
seien nach innen so dass man es halt
außen nicht lesen kann das ist ja auch
schon so viel war ja also ich wäre ja
eine rannten burgund war heute morgen
kurz nach 8 da einer der ersten hat man
kann eigentlich gar nicht in die
situation kommen so habe ich zumindest
wahrgenommen dass man den jetzt falsch
faltet ja also klar bei den kreuzen muss
man sich kurz einmal sortieren das sind
ja wirklich zwei lange listen die da
überfallen aber dann ist es eigentlich
hier ist es wirklich muss man sagen hier
ist eine riesige panne denn armin
laschet muss das natürlich klar sein wie
man in gefaltet und auch der wahlleiter
hätte eingreifen müssen er hätte ihn
zurück in die kabine mit einem neuen
wahlzettel das alles noch mal
wiederholen müssen also das wirklich
eine riesige fahne wenn wir noch mal auf
die bilder schon das ist der moment wo
der wahlleiter deutschland kommen müssen
und sagen was moment stoppt für uns
darum müssen wir jetzt noch mal
wiederholen wo er schon ein bisschen
irritation da wahllokal es dauerte
nämlich bei amiga schiedsfrau vor allen
dingen ein bisschen länger sie hatte
offenbar erst briefwahl beantragt und
sich dann noch entschieden eben doch ins
wahllokal zu gehen mit ihrem mann
deswegen hatte sie da erst die falschen
unterlagen dabei das dauerte auch da
schon ein bisschen länger aus der
fußballwelt kommt mir da der spruch in
den sinn irgendwie erst hatten wir kein
glück und dann kam auch noch pech dazu
oder so was ja auch das ist halt auch
ein bisschen tennis welt wenn wir schon
jetzt beim sport sind anfangs terror
also das ist eigentlich ist das ding ist
eigentlich klar und keiner rechnet damit
dass man in so einer situation was
passiert was haben wir uns alle
ausgemalt in den letzten wochen und
monaten wie dieser bundestagswahlkampf
zu ende gehen könnte und jetzt sprechen
wir darüber dass ausgerechnet einer der
drei wichtigsten irgendwie das ding gar
falsch halte die weiterreichenden sie
das passt irgendwie auch zu armin
laschet er hat ja öfter mal ein bisschen
pech hat in diesem wahlkampf vorsichtig
formuliert ist das eine typische nummer
das werden wir zu viel aber der das kopf
an kopf rennen scheint köpfe zu
vertreten also du hast wirklich das
gefühl ich davon gegner aus albig ein
wenig vorstellen dass er sagt jetzt
zeige ich euch mal dass ich die zwei
kreuze im allerersten
treibt das auf die stühle dass er seinem
sich selber weh tut die partei aber
ja es ist so ein bisschen
warum behauptet man schneller sich jetzt
wo am ende fehlt eine stimme und diese
wird
nein das wird nicht bei der kamera
[Musik]